the agenda is set I'm bring cough in
Berlin it's time to talk Putin the peace
broker is russia's president suddenly
the go-to good guy US policy on Syria
does the world's only superpower want to
give up its global police job and the
final stretch of campaigning what's at
stake in Sunday's German election Oh
welcome to the show everyone I've
invited three people today to talk argue
and pry apart these headlines my first
guest is Hans Pfeiffer he is one of dw's
veteran political correspondence here in
Berlin and Hans is going to be our
insider to date on the German election
how it's good to have you on the show my
second guest is a law professor from
Northwestern University in Chicago I'm
happy to welcome to the show david
shaffer he is on the show with us he's
in Berlin this fall riding on u.s.
foreign policy David's going to tell us
why Obama and the u.s. have not lost
credibility in the Syrian crisis and my
next guest spends a lot of time in front
of the Russian embassy here in Berlin he
organizes protests against corruption in
his home country I'm happy to welcome to
the show Ilya Rifkin Ilya you are not a
fan of Vladimir Putin we know that do
you think that the Syrian crisis though
has drawn out a completely different
side of him I mean is he headed for a
Nobel Peace Prize now I think it's
possible that he got a Nobel Peace Prize
for what he does because it's such
absurd situation and say I really think
you could get a Nobel Peace Prize not
really you do not write a good all right
that's the Russian I really hear that
yeah that's just the irony ok because on
this chemical weapons since this rocket
yeah it was fine király Cletus and
Cyrillic letters yes Cyrillic letters
and you you're saying they were made by
the Russians the
weapons that ability is Syria okay all
right but there's those weapons though
could have been stolen we don't know
right yeah it could be stolen i don't
but it's also responsibility of russia
russian state to keep chemical weapons
to keep it a secret but what I mean the
rebels could have been involved without
you right i mean the rebels also could
have some type of of guilt in this yes i
am not i don't know who use it but the
fact it does this chemical weapons came
from Russia but you okay but you still
think that Putin has a lot to answer for
David what do you think what's the word
on Putin now I mean he's looking very
good on the world stage well he is but
you know you never want to underestimate
Vladimir Putin he has long history of
the Cold War as part of his background
in the KGB he's been very methodical in
the way he has ruled russia over the
last what 12 13 14 years in the sense
that he's always looking for the
advantage that Russia can seize in what
I would call sort of the post-cold war
struggle with the United States which we
obviously are still in would you agree
with that hunt yeah I would agree with
of course and I think from the German
perspective Germans are kind of
reluctant about the situation now that
there is no military action at the
moment so no matter what the the
diplomatic dealers are what the what the
intention of Vladimir Putin is that is
kind of good not to have a military
action at the moment because Germany
really feared to get into that in the
region so right the Germans are afraid
of the military action but the big
question that people are asking right
now is what is Vladimir Putin up to
suddenly Russia appears to be paving a
possible road to peace in Syria last
week's plan for Moscow defense Syria's
chemical weapons under international
control did more than shocked the world
it changed the discussion about Syria's
future now some people are daring to ask
if peace in the near
could be possible piece made not by the
UN or the US but by Vladimir Putin no
one has ever accused Vladimir Putin of
being soft after the former KGB officer
took over Russia decade after the
collapse of the Soviet Union he moved
swiftly to crush a rebellion in renegade
Chechnya the Russian president is also
not known for tolerating internal
dissent during his terms at the
country's helm Putin has cracked down on
dissenting voices and press freedom
within Russia he's also supported allies
abroad like the Assad regime in Syria
that do the same much of the Russian
presidents mystique and popularity at
home is built on a macho image carefully
cultured and showcased on national
television now he sees the opportunity
to take on a new role on the world stage
that of international mediator islaam
but can Russia's top guy president
really turn into Vladimir Putin the
peacemaker hooting he's not you I mean
that's what people are saying Putin is
the peacemaker now Elliot um he you have
to give him credit he definitely stole
the thunder away from Obama with this
plan for the chemical weapons yes he did
someone good thing for Obama but I don't
know if it's a good decision for Syrian
people because he stopped a war that for
where will involve that American army
but civil war in Syria goes on and if do
you think he cares about the welfare of
the Syrian people mm I think he cares
about military base in Tarsus that's
only one Russian military base in
Mediterranean and also hears about
Russia's the Russian military is right i
mean is that what we're looking at here
we're looking at a real political here
he's not really worried about all of
these refugees he's worried basically
about
his image well I think that's correct
you know no one I think it's premature
to call anyone a peacemaker yet with
respect to Syria far too premature
certainly for Vladimir Putin this is a
man who I think tries to seize every
opportunity he can to trump the united
states that doesn't mean in a
necessarily sort of aggressive
destructive sense but i think he's very
cognizant of what the image of russia
was during the soviet years he wants to
restore that image as a major power in
the world and he'll take advantage of
situations to do that but sometimes
those situations will actually be
beneficial for larger objectives that
the United States and other countries
might want to join in is that I don't
think it's for the purpose of world
peace that Vladimir Putin actually
undertakes as an issue is it beneficial
to the world behinds that people are now
saying Putin has proposed peace to
prevent Obama from going to war well
it's a long way in two peas and Syria so
it might be beneficial we have to wait
for that but I would say if there would
be real peace in Syria and if there
would be a change in the situation for
the better of the people of Syria it
would be beneficial but I agree that
it's not the intention of Vladimir Putin
to be the world peace maker it's more
about to be kind of a world ruler and to
be on top with in the old circle of the
old elite of people who deal with the
problems in the world and it's all about
power is that what it is Ilya yes I'm a
grave yeah but I would also say don't
don't understate the importance of
Sergey Lavrov in this entire equation in
fact he might be the one who in the end
is viewed as the the the real actor on
behalf of Russia to cut a deal would not
only with the United States but to
follow through with that deal in terms
of enforcing it with Syria Lavrov may be
the sort of the operative that actually
gets this done and I'm not so certain
that history will conclude that it was
Putin who had the vision for this
particular outcome in Syria what kind of
vision
yeah what vision does Putin have well I
don't know what that is he's a man of
considerable narcissistic character he's
also a man who is very tactfully leading
Russia back to a position of major power
status but without necessarily the
assets to back it up in terms of
military etc what do you think what's
Putin's vision for the world um putian
told that for him is breakdown of suing
the soviet union's the biggest hill
political disaster and his idea is to
restore the might that soviet union has
or is a kind of revenge East politics
that he he want to restore might of
Soviet or Tsarist Empire so he still
he's still fighting the Cold War yes
yeah and I think it's a new front line I
mean Syria is the new front line of that
cold war but we've had other front lines
since the end of the Cold War whether it
be the former Yugoslavia Kosovo
Afghanistan Iraq where Russia has
countered the West yeah so it's it's a
new battlefield but it's one that I
think Putin is very comfortable with
because his entire professional
background has been to play with in that
battlefield right i mean he is a KGB
manner he was a KGB man in germany yeah
here in jeopardy I think I well he's one
of the those politicians who did not
arrive in the new structures of a
globalized world so he make divisions in
the world between Russia between the
United States and all those old blocks
and countries but he's not thinking
networks or in globalized structures
which modern governments do or should do
and the world I mean it's like he looks
like a dinosaur I mean you were saying
Iliad that he is always playing on these
deep conservative values the
the Orthodox Church for example the KGB
working together something that Stalin
would have maybe you know in in a back
room also supported immediately when is
he going to come into the 21st century I
think that in 21st century is revival
also of some are high chol or old
ideologist like political Islamism and
so on and some for example someone
speaker of Russian Orthodox Church the
speaker of the Russian Orthodox Church
here says that the government or
political of Iran is good I me doesn't
have a good track record with things
like Iran or North Korea as far as
bringing peace to those situations let
me ask you all what's going to happen
next year in Sochi is that going to be a
public relations disaster for Putin
because we see already in Berlin there
are protesting one after another against
the anti-gay law and against the
Olympics being held in Sochi so are we
moving toward are we seeing a tsunami
coming well I don't think the United
States will in any way pull out of those
Olympics I mean we've done that before
and it's a bridge that a lot of people
didn't like crossing I don't think we're
going to cross that bridge again but i
do think from the United States point of
view there will be a very affirmative
affirmation of civil rights and of other
issues that that we are a difference
with with the Russian government in
terms of what public officials say what
they say on the ground in Sochi what the
athletes themselves may say as athletes
they will probably come with symbolic
references to gay rights with them and
some of them are gay yeah some of them
are you I mean what do you say about
this
don't you think that Sochi is a time
bomb that's going to explode in Putin's
face exactly I I think that not only gay
rights but also Sochi is a country of
cannot seat of check asian people and
now many thousands of circassians want
repet rate from cydia back to Russia
back to this Black Sea region and Putin
don't let this people return that's one
more problem I'm not very confident that
we will see that many protests in TV
they might also be the protests in
Russia but because it's so important for
Russia to to make success out of these
games and people well the audience the
people who watch the Olympic Games they
are pretty fast and forgetting about all
the problems and this is what we've seen
in picking where they have also been
protests and there also have been
athletes who in advance before the game
started said well we have to take care
about you maybe like we didn't see a
rest taking place even in Beijing with
the Olympics and what we could see now
in Sochi we could see people on the
street being arrested by the police
doing something like wait wait till this
game started you won't see them maybe a
kinder a kinda agent yeah there were
there were there international cameras
and international reporters that won't
be the places well just around the
stadium still be some reporters who want
to pursue that story yeah Christian
kinou yori I think when the game started
and after one week like that's what
we've seen here in Germany everybody
talks about the medals yeah and it's
getting pretty fast then the athletes in
advance they say well let's talk about
human rights but when they're getting in
danger of not after four years of
training getting the medal let's wait
for the first openly gay athlete to get
away metal all right yeah that's right
listen we'll see what happens is you but
let's move on and talk about the irony
here the world is talking about Russian
President Putin whenever Syria's
mentioned but wasn't it US President
Obama if you drew that red line the
Pentagon was ready a couple of weeks ago
to flex the muscles
but only a World Police Force cam but
ask Americans about Syria today and the
majority will tell you that they want to
stay out of the Civil War America the
superpower is tired of picking up the
slack when the rest of the world drops
the enforcement ball the age of
diplomacy shared with the u.s. not
always led by the u.s. may now be upon
us 12 years after the 911 attacks that
led to wars in Afghanistan and Iraq a
majority of Americans say they're
against involvement in another armed
conflict Barack Obama's addressed the
nation last week reflected that America
is not the world's policeman terrible
things happen across the globe and it is
beyond our means to right every wrong
but when with modest effort and risk we
can stop children from being gassed to
death and thereby make our own children
safer over the long run I believe we
should act many suspect Russia's
proposal for Syria to give up its
chemical weapons is just a plot to buy
time for Assad and the u.s. hasn't taken
the possibility of a military strike off
the table but in the future how much
will the u.s. be able to accomplish with
modest effort and risk is Washington
going to rely more on diplomacy and less
on military might what do you think
David are we looking at world police
light now with Obama well essentially
you know remember the President Obama
first of all wants to get us out of wars
and he's been doing that with Iraq and
Afghanistan but at the same time he's
very attracted to a sort of stealth
light footprint approach to various
military challenges as opposed to the
heavy footprint he goes in any sort of
tip toes in and tip toes out with
sophisticated technology I mean the
whole drone attack issue which we've
much debated but it is what he prefers
so the the Syrian situation has
presented him with an opportunity
frankly for a limited strike if
necessary
that is that is what he would that would
be a natural option for him to actually
choose as opposed to any sort of
large-scale intervention and there's a
paradox in that because you know he also
speaks of protecting civilian
populations and and of atrocities which
you cannot really do with missile
strikes but it's his sort of small step
approach which which means that
enforcement under Obama is a very
different concept is it is is I don't
know if it's that simple you know the
latest poll came out asking Americans
about being the world police found that
two and five americans believe the
United States has an obligation to
punish foreign governments that deploy
weapons of mass destruction to kill
civilians only two and five a majority
of Americans say we are not the
enforcers so there's an identity crisis
right now and the Russians Elliott
Moscow loves that identity crisis and
the Germans well I think they terrified
of that they're losing their police
officer I don't think that well i think
that the Germans still think that when
it comes to to final decisions there
still is this policeman the United
States and that because they are not
that many alternatives they're not that
many a Europe is not the world's
policeman they are not ready for that
they have not they have not a congruent
politics or the employee policies like
in Libya and say I think likely Fifi if
you see Germany or the German Chancellor
it's more waiting for American action
and we won't be if American is not doing
it we will do it but there's there's a
changed reality now which is that when
first of all the the reality is the
United States continues to have the
military assets that are indispensable
to any effective intervention militarily
anywhere in the world airlift
capabilities etc and other nations
sometimes want to draw upon those assets
the French like to do so for example if
they go into Mali but I think under the
Obama administration there
been a tendency to say yes we want to
maintain that asset base but we want to
deploy it with more sophistication we
want to deploy it with multilateral
diplomatic support when possible I think
the interesting thing about Syria and
the red line is that President Obama
took us to a new place which he said
let's enforce an international norm we
must enforce an international norm we
must enforce international law now that
that's a fairly bold new statement by an
American president to say we're going to
use military force to enforce
international law puts him at odds with
Russia yes what I'm eventing from Obama
is more consistent politic because now I
don't understand what Obama really if he
has a vision for Syria and for Middle
East he started some very offensive do
you expect him aledo is he supposed to
have a clear vision for what happens to
Syria yes because America is a
superpower and to be a superpower is
also responsibility and America support
Israel and America have very close
connections to Qatar and to Saudi Arabia
and so on and two in this situation
america couldn't be unresponsible he
acts responsible because we just talked
about Putin and I think we agree that
booting is using his power just to gain
more power and when we talk about
politics in Syria of the United States
well I have the impression that they use
their power to see for political
solutions for for maybe also better
outcome for Syria and so I think what
Obama was doing
is like it is compared to the former
government with under george w bush it
is a change because it is trying to make
politics together in an international
and it's a change because obama doesn't
think in terms of linear diplomacy he
deals with circumstances as they arise
and he does take the long-term view so
that if there are hills and valleys
along the way to get to that long-term
objective I think he's prepared to
accept that he's also prepared sometimes
to accept simply the criticism and and
the the haranguing that that comes his
way particularly by the Republicans to
get to that objective on Syria you know
it's a it's a it's a diplomacy has
proven to be complex and yet in the end
it may prove to get us to the right
objective okay well i would say they
don't thing about the vision yeah i
didn't i don't i'm not sure if you
always need a clear vision for what's
going on in Syria and 10 or 20 years but
because you cannot play plane you cannot
plan that and so that it might be used
for like where did the german chancellor
was very successful in moving step by
step and end to to watch out carefully
for what's going on if you do a next
step what will happen then and then it
might be that it might be worth feel
mighty good let me reach them that's
been written about obama in Syria but by
forgetting to first seek a peaceful
hopefully successful resolution to the
Syrian problem President Obama did not
choose to play the chessboard nearly as
clever as Vladimir Putin a lot of people
say that he missed his opportunity in
Syria to earn the Nobel Peace Prize that
he was given several years ago well I I
would take some issue with that remember
the United States the United Kingdom in
France for two years have tried to move
very assertive resolutions through the
Security Council and they've been
blocked consistently in doing so so they
get by Russian trans now so they've
tried to approach this issue of the
civil
or in the atrocities in Syria in a
multilateral approach and they've been
thwarted by doing so now you if you want
a fault President Obama for not having
taken a clearly you know aggressive
military approach to Syria over the last
twenty year two years you may do so I
mean that is a fair argument because
there is a responsibility to try to
protect those civilians and he did he
did draw a line diplomatically and that
he has stated that he wants Assad to go
white instead of invoking the chemical
weapons ban in Syria why didn't he come
out and invoke the principle of
collective self-defense that we will not
allow neighboring states like Turkey
Jordan Israel to be threatened by a
dictator who will throw out sarin gas
well Brett I would agree with you on
that I think that the better legal
rationale for the use of force against
the Syrian chemical weapons stocks is
one of collective self-defense as
opposed to enforcement of a legal norm
which has its great attractions mean
international lawyers and I'm one of
them love that argument we'd love to see
that institutionalized somehow but under
current international law I think the
far better rationale would be one of
collective self-defense whereby you have
Turkey why do you think though that we
bomb did not go for that because it
seems almost like common sense because
first there may be some difficulty with
those countries in actually getting a
formal request of that character because
it signals that that country itself
considers itself to be in some sort of
armed conflict with Syria to ask for
assistance in collective self-defense
now I would argue that they should be
able to overcome that concern they're
easily retain their size refugees that's
a rare and even even yesterday Turkey
had to shoot down a Syrian helicopter
that came across the border and intruded
upon their their their territorial space
there have been so many examples of both
shellings of refugee flows etc where I
would argue that neighboring countries
are essentially under armed attack at
this point because of the spillover of
the Civil War so there's more than
enough latitude to seek collective
before
we move on let me ask all of you on is
Obama and his identity of what the
United States is in the world is he
fighting right now the legacy of the
George W Bush Doctrine absolutely and he
will admit to that I mean I think he
says it in so many different ways he's
getting he wants to get us out of wars
as opposed to take us into Wars he does
not I I don't know of a single speech
where like the George W Bush speeches
where he talks about promoting democracy
around the world he approaches it very
very differently that whole concept so I
think there is a dramatic difference
between the two what do you think well I
think it's not only Obama it's also the
Democratic Party so we always point on
one person but there are many people in
the administration who were with him who
share the same kind of approach to
politics and I think also in the Obama
government administration it's a lot
about money as well because the wars
have been very expensive for the US the
crisis was deep and the outcome of the
walls we had in Afghanistan and Iraq is
unclear in its very uncertain has
Germany been a really good friend to
Obama as he tries to clean up the bush
mess I mean why hasn't Germany been more
vocal in in saying that the this this
idea of a world where we have more
alliance is where we do work together
why is it in Germany a bigger
cheerleader that or do you think Germany
could be a louder to your leader I mean
Germany and Russia are in bed with each
other many times when it sometimes it
looks very very awkward but we have a
different Chancellor now and Chancellor
Merkel has a different approach to
politics it's a what she called
equidistance to two different
governments and no matter if it's
poutine Obama that's that's a cop-out
though isn't it I mean wouldn't it
doesn't it make sense for Germany to be
more aligned with the West with the
United States then with them with the
Russia that Ilya of course is fighting
to change well in if you if you listen
to the speeches or
Makka there is a big difference because
she criticizes openly Vladimir Putin
when she visits him and she's talking
about human rights and she also
criticizes President Obama but she's
more careful about that and I think that
well I think they are closer allies than
many people well there's a lot about
talking about Obama and McAdoo they have
problems should she supported that you
know what I think the United States
really would would desire from Germany
and we get some of it but is what I
would call the soft diplomatic foot
namely when we need Germany at the UN to
support something in the Security
Council whether it's a member or not at
that point when we need Germany and NATO
when we need Germany to support
humanitarian efforts with refugees and
they do this so substantially in this
country those kinds of soft diplomatic
footprints are extremely important and
you know the United States i've never
heard of many arguments that oh we want
the german army to march in with us you
know to some location sometimes we want
them in afghanistan to help with at
least accept yeah that's going to take
us to our third topic today and of
course that's the election a week from
now Germany may have a new chancellor
and a new government or maybe not voters
go to the election box on Sunday but
poll after poll tells us don't expect
much change this election has been a
major non headliner so far the great
yawn some have caught it we want to wake
up the sleeping public today a lot is at
stake Germany is Europe's strongest
country and it calls the shots on many
issues here so on Sunday voters here
will be deciding the fate of the entire
continent that is anything but a sleeper
opinion polls put Angela Merkel's
Christian Democrats ahead in the run-up
to Germany's parliamentary election she
says only her government can steer a
stable course in Germany and Europe and
claims opposition plans would prove
disastrous therefore I since our
businesses should be allowed to grow and
create jobs they shouldn't be crippled
by tax hikes or
gandhi's of Sun voters in state
elections in Bavaria last weekend Hannah
conservatives there a decisive victory
that result is given a boost to miracle
in the final days of the campaign but it
was coupled with a poor showing for her
coalition partners the Free Democrats if
they do badly at the national level two
miracle could be looking for a different
party to share government the opposition
Social Democrats have lagged behind
throughout the campaign not helped by a
series of gaffes by pair Steinbrueck
their candidate for Chancellor but some
polls suggest it could be a close race
at the finish so we'll issues or
personalities to side the German
election hans how much personality has
there been of this campaign well i mean
come on yeah we were we're not talking
that much about parties which was in the
past always in Germany we don't vote the
Chancellor we vote the parties right
then vote in the parliament the
Chancellor but so it was a lot about
personality and this campaign because
Chancellor Merkel is one of the most
popular politicians in Germany and she's
much more popular than peer Steinbrueck
the social democrat who wants to be
Chancellor so there's much talking about
the personality is not not that much
talking about the the content even if
it's not a lot of talk period right at
me a lot of people just start interested
I mean uncle America it's important to
note is the most popular politician in
Germany you have all the politicians
everybody loves uncle me but I think the
reason is right away for her if you if
you have a close look we always talk
about the the persons in the front line
but if you if you look a little bit
closer to the programs of the parties no
matter which coalition will govern in
Germany to of cover Chancellor Merkel
will not govern by her own her party the
Conservatives are not strong enough says
so she has to look for her for a
coalition partner but if no matter with
whom she will govern or no matter if the
Social Democrats will govern with
another party there won't be this is
what I think there won't be major
differences in politics
are relatively similar yeah so that's
why right so we don't have a lot of
competing ideas here that's why um but
you know as an American I am savoring
this because this is so rational so calm
so policy oriented I heard that during
the debate there was a long discussion
about pensions you this would never
happen in the United States it would
always descend into some sort of you
know lines of retort and and accusations
and also veering away from hard policy
discussions so i think i want to give
some credit to the Germans actually it's
nice occasionally to have a boring
election where maybe the fine tune
issues of pension reform are at issue
but also where you have moments of of
some comedy I noted you know with the
the the the Merkel you're in good hands
and then I see a magazine cover with the
SP with Steinberg showing us the bad
hand and that was a nice way to sort of
encapsulate whatever dichotomy there is
between them yeah good and bad Ilya do
you agree here that a boring election is
a good election hmm yeah in the
elections this election in Germany are
quite similar to election in Russian
because everybody knows who will be the
next Chancellor and which party got the
greatest the biggest duty percentage
right but there's a little bit of
difference between a jury a rush I come
with their make one note because I don't
think that it's a boring election well
ok it no matter who will govern it will
be roundabout the same direction they
will move in the future we will be we
will be we will take care the same way
off the euro crisis the relationship to
the United States won't change no matter
if it's Angela Merkel or if it's /
steinberg but it is not boring if
look to what the talking is about so we
were talking about minimum wages shall
we have minimum wages in Germany shall
we change this politics should there be
more social security also for the Pure
Ones how do we deal with is this so I
think it also is a chance to talk about
politics and not only about these like
we have it in the US between Tea Party
and Democrats with us just shouting and
shouting with no outcomes and density
yeah but I would say it is also
different to Russia because we're not
talking about power but we still talk
about politics he and jamie altar in
these election times it doesn't seem to
be as destructive a political process in
a campaign season here as one finds it
in the united states and that's what i
find sort of relaxing without observing
this particular election I mean these
are also issues of luxury right to
talking about a minimum wage talking
about the pension plan you're not
talking about existential issues for the
country i mean germany is in a really
good place now Germany is the most
popular country in the world right now
Hans how does that feel I mean you got
everyone loves Germany yeah there's a
white Jason tree it feels pretty
comfortable of course yeah and I think
this is why the the election of
Chancellor Merkel is not in danger
because there is the most people say
that they are confident and that they
are satisfied with the style Chancellor
Merkel governs and which was in these
this gesture of peer steinbrück she did
he did some other gestures about he was
asked in the same photo series what do
you think about the way Angela Merkel
handled the crisis one very good and 10
very bad and he said well not so good
but he showed he made another sign on
his back too so he's very confident and
he liked the style she managed the
crisis so he likes her crisis maybe he
was the finance ministers the finance
minister the Social Democrats supported
the way they well to be honest they both
handle the crisis together it was
Beckham only Michael but but what about
you know things are
incredibly good in Germany right now and
and but let me there I mean there are
there are economic problems and there is
growing poverty in the country but
because things seemed to be going so
good does that create a level of
complacency now isn't that why so many
people say they're not interested in the
election I'm not sure I'm not sure about
this if we we have to be careful about
calling these problems Germany has as
luxurious problem because people who
live here they don't know other
countries like most like also the United
States their economical problems are
luxury problems compared to the problems
Africa has but it's still a very deep
having problems the politics have to
take care about and we have problems
here in Germany with poverty and we have
a growing problem with that say it is
the responsibility of the politicians to
take care of this and not only being
like very smooth about it all and say
okay we can be happy and just go on so
in the Greeks the Greek politician and
they don't they they don't hide it at
all they say she's a mean woman yeah
from says nothing and she's tough I
think this is a this is this is one
problem of the government of Angela
Merkel did and we were talking about
Syria we were talking about the
relationship to Russia and the US that
Germany as a country not only Merkel is
not very interested and concerned about
the whole world we are we don't want to
be the world we smell even we care about
Europe because it affects us and the
euro crisis was was a big danger for
Germany but we are not much the the
revolutions and the Arabian world Arab
world or what's going on in Syria yes
politics is local I mean that's what you
that's what people say everywhere
politics is local but it's it's in fact
it is more than local because we are a
strong economy with with the deep bound
boundaries to to Asia to Russia to to
effort to all over the world so so it's
not only local and I would say that
he should learn what Obama
administration is asking for that we
should think more in international terms
and we should do you think the German
voter is aware I was in Portugal last
week and I talked to some people in
Lisbon about what they think of Germany
and the German government and I heard
only positive things um I heard a lot of
people saying we need to be more like
the Germans on because at the end of the
day the Germans are in charge you would
never hear a German politician say that
we are in charge no but I think this is
this is also part of our history because
Germany it's still even if it's so long
ago the Second World War and the the the
time of national socialism here in
Germany weird little bit afraid of this
role of being in charge if you tell
others and we step down we're running
out of time we've got about a minute
here let me ask all three of you a week
from now if we were sitting here who are
we going to be talking about who will
win yeah yeah I start with you who's
going to be who's going to be the winner
Dex way he's going to be the Chancellor
Christian Democrats the Christian
Democrats an angle America will stay
chance yes all right David what would
you say I think all the signs point
towards that at this point so yes mm-hmm
and Christian Democrats and
ungrammatical and do you think that she
will stay with the with the fdp I'm not
sure you're not it said that's a tough
one to call right I I'm not sure because
right I'm not sure if she they will gain
enough all right all right well the
election is coming up next Sunday and DW
is the right address for the best
coverage of the German election join me
next Sunday I'll anchor our live
coverage as the numbers come in and the
winners are revealed exclusive
interviews with the candidates and top
analysis of the results it all starts at
three thirty p.m. UTC that's 5 30 here
in Berlin 1130am eastern standard time
in the US and you can contact me anytime
with your thoughts on the election tweet
me at brent gough TV and you can email
us as well agenda english at the WD you
see the let the address right there on
your screen all right next week on
agenda smart talk on the german election
that was I'm Brent Goff in Berlin join
me next time when I
set the agenda
you